after the end of the arab-israel war
aerial surveys spot a huge circular
stone pattern on the ground prior to its
discovery no written record exists of
this mysterious structure experts put
forward a number of theories this looks
to me a kind of ceremonial feature that
it have also practical functions such as
defensive a tower of some sort but don't
see this as being a fortress I see it as
being sacred space what is really
surprising is the perfection of these
circles the outer stone wall stretches
508 feet across the size of the LA
Dodgers Stadium
experts are baffled as to who built the
stone circles and why this is not
primitive people just saying let's build
something roughly that shape they've
measured it out carefully and then
they've built it using gigantic stones
that would have been a major undertaking
Yonatan maserati has spent three years
excavating the mysterious ruins the
layout of the site makes my's Rocchi
suspect the mysterious ancient builders
could have used this as an elaborate
burial place looking around us you can
see here the actual entrance to the
chamber tomb and from this opening we
can get into the tomb but if this was a
tomb where are all the bodies looking
again at the circular layout some
archeologists disagree with the burial
Theory instead they see similarities
with other ancient structures ones that
could track the passing of time
the Northeast gate is due to the
somersault ease there are two registers
on the eastern part of the site which
are marking the days of the equinox so
we are forced to conclude that there are
relationship between the way this site
was constructed and astronomical bodies
that were important to those people
Maserati has discovered that the size of
the stones and the way they are cut is
different between the outer walls and
the central Mound
this suggests they come from different
times this could explain the two
conflicting theories for the site's
purpose
the earlier phase an early Bronze Age
was used as ceremonial center and it's a
calendar and then 1500 BC there were
other people no much that came here
built a burial tomb so two distinct
phases two different stories two
different cultures
you